[Laughter]
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soccer physics yeah
we have had a strange day a strange day
I'm sure I can't even begin to describe
how we shouldn't be recording this after
the day that we have had but it'll come
in bits and pieces over the for games
okay each other's buttons
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait table tug don't look over shut up
we've got more than that
like Deez Nuts God it was the taste of
my grundle dis ways to know for me
[Music]
well are we shirtless why not
exactly that reason you're too
distracted by the pecs you can't beat I
will I'm not gonna do a damn thing
oh you thought it was futbol americano
but you roll jelly on my set ball what
happened all my skills it's a little
slippery well good for you there buddy
boo no no I'm not looking I can see it
so now all right you are you I'll
control my goalie and your front man how
do I
you control your goalie in my friend
what is that de D okay all right it
dreaming we're both on each other's
defenders okay each other scores as well
okay which goes left is me yeah left it
all that was a goal for you okay good so
you got a goal for me you actually have
to play yeah I'm gonna score on it
myself
[Music]
don't you you don't do I'm coming for
you okay you want for your fight oh well
I mean that's enough to do but I'll just
move yeah keep going keep pushing no I
just kiss at the top of your head too
good I am too good got a single point
oh yeah though comeback of the century
ha
[Laughter]
No what are we doing so stupid so stupid
screams wait a minute I remember I have
this power
hello everybody Wow it's been a while
Wainwright wait hahaha i won nuh-uh
we played a practice round I was I'm
blue and he's red one more for all the
beat one more one more for all the beams
we'll go back to one button winner takes
all
okay and if I lose everyone's gonna see
that I wanted to regain all the B
[Applause]
oh we've got a shouldn't we should
mention Regent Park
you know everyone is counting whoa what
happened in Legion parks killed me is
still her no gay was stupid all tied up
maybe ho yes yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out Wade's channel for the stuff
they've done and if you play this game
record it with your best friend I want
to see you how you playing it with your
friends if you're just the same as us
which I imagine you are then you played
it fun don't do that wait don't do that
to me
thank you everybody again for watching
and as always we will see you in the
next video
[Music]